are we wedding planning we are
you and zach are still happily together
it seems that way
how are things yes we are happily
together in fact
he's around here somewhere with me he's
here he is here
oh we should pull him out on stage i
feel like zach wouldn't love that though
he's he would be like hey what's up okay
i'm gonna go now it's not his thing
he always seemed like the person who
truly was nominated by a family member
and kind of found his way onto reality
tv like how does he feel about this life
in the spotlight now
100 i feel like he definitely
embraces it because of me and um
at the same time it does give him a
platform to try to
bring more awareness to mental health
and mental illness and
so yeah i think he's doing a pretty good
job with it so how are you guys doing
are we wedding planning where are we at
we are
taking it slow at the moment we're doing
well we're doing very very well but at
the same time
um we kind of rushed you know to get
this little thing on my finger
um and right now we're just having fun
dating each other being engaged
dating couple you've been spending a lot
of time in new york right
how is that going for you as a
california girl i actually love it you
do
it's like it's the point where like why
did i want to be by coastal i should
just like
move on over are you gonna move to new
york i believe so
really i mean there's still some things
i have to work out i feel like um
you know my family's still down here and
and i do have a place of my own but um
i really just want a home base and i
want like a firm foundation and
something i feel like new york might be
it
wow why new york instead of california
because you guys could have gone
either way well i think also zach
has a really established business out
there that he is doing so much good that
i can't
i couldn't sleep at night knowing that i
ripped him away from doing that
um i think he still has some business he
needs to do but also the same time i've
been wanting to move to new york forever
and so this is kind of like i don't know
the perfect storm if you will
what have you learned about each other
in these weeks since the show ended and
you've been living out in the real world
um he's a very mature man um
i've learned that we love to hear we'd
love to hear
that okay it's definitely very different
than what i'm used to
but i feel like um fights actually don't
have to last six hours eight hours or go
to the next day
wow and i think um that's one lesson
that i've learned
more so recently that i'm really
thanking my lucky stars for
wow okay i love hearing this because
what you hear from many couples and not
in a bad way but many couples say that
after they get off the show it's a
really tough period because you're
coming off the show and you're trying to
figure things out have you guys had
struggles or has it felt like wow this
is actually pretty easy
it's pretty easy um but i feel like
absolutely like any
um relationship we've had struggles yeah
i mean we just went from
living apart you know him in new york
meet orange county
to me moving in basically on top of each
other in a new york city apartment
and i'm just like hi i can't go anywhere
this is home
it's all happening so it's a lot to
juggle we're good
we're engaged my god we're
we're engaged right now yeah we are now
claire and dale
have broken up have you talked to either
of them
and what would you say to them about
what they're kind of going through right
now i haven't spoken to dale i did reach
out to claire
honestly i would just say
keep to your eyes as selves i feel like
it's really easy to get
wrapped up in wanting to have your voice
heard and it makes it really messy
and you guys are both hurting right now
so just
you know yeah reach out to your loved
ones and your friends and your family
you can confide in but
just stay out of media if that's how you
want to express yourself and you want to
be toxic and rude
go for it and if you want to express
yourself with your dildo and think
you're ready for an
engagement you can do that tasha so much
discussion about the women this season
having been on the shows what is it like
for you to watch the way these women are
treating each other
oh boy i i really she said oh
boy well i remember what it's like being
in that house and just
how when tension is high it is high
you don't want to even sleep you don't
want to get ready you don't do anything
for these women
um i don't i don't wish i was there
let's just say that
it's interesting to hear you say that
though because we've also seen so many
friendships come out of the franchise
so it really seems like this season
these women
there's a lot of toxicity do you find it
to be an unusual amount or what do you
think
i think so i i don't remember a group of
women being this
i don't know manipulative and
condescending towards one another
i don't know um i hope it doesn't
continue on
so matt's done a pretty good job with
nipping it in the bud i hope
it just continues that way when you are
watching some of these women i think
especially with victoria some fans have
wondered
is this real i mean there's some people
wondering is she
acting is she auditioning on this show
what do you think
i mean i think at this point it would be
exhausting to be keeping it up
she's meryl streep if she's out i mean
it's phenomenal worth it
it's phenomenal work i think that's just
her
we're gonna see her on women tell all
what's your advice for victoria
as she heads to the tell-all to present
herself how should she do it
just own up to everything you've said
okay and just
um apologize it's been
hard to tell which of the women if any
are not
involved at all in any of this um but
katie's name has come up people have
really rallied around katie
next bachelorette do you like katie do
you like somebody else who are your
picks
i think she's really sweet but i also
um i really like rachel i really like
brie
there's a couple of good girls in there
okay so if you had to pick a couple i
mean this is the person who's going to
succeed you
tasia oh my god who should it be um
i think katie would be a good choice and
i wanted to get your thoughts on that
because
it's a reality show um but you know
you've also kind of
i guess got to take responsibility of
what goes on tv sometimes
we saw it all get resolved last night
what do you think should any of this
have been shown should more of it have
been cut out
how do you feel to be honest i think it
kind of um
showed us how matt would handle this
situation um
and it showed us i fell in love with
matt a little bit more with how he
handled the situations and calling
you know the girls out but also being
like i need to set a standard for the
women
and that's not who i want to be with so
um
i think that it's a little bit amplified
these days
um but i think it's important to see
what's happening behind the scenes
and and to really know what's going on
in the house
in order for people to get context about
who these people are
you